welcome to this video Matt's hands
probably so the winner and chat add some
fun and games recently with that let's
see with this b6 line
yeah people tend to know it too don't
know that and then against unprepared
players it is some quite often
interesting yeah that's in fact a good
line what you did here this Queen g4 and
back the ideas at night e 2 2 g-3 and
later we'll learn attack the porn queen
only one is kind of out of the way oh
that is not a common way to play it
funny so do i want to take on f1 first
Joe I'm probably and now yeah i guess i
will take that's interesting now i'm
even getting to f5 right or he wants to
take it seven that's hard to believe
maybe no he actually allows night at
five but okay if i go night at five i
have some problem a problem of course
with castling can also now it still
looks like a very natural move so let's
do that
ok some Queen sorry an IG three coming
up
Quincy 697 and f6 this is an idea I hear
that's actually interesting let's set
set set probably better right at the
taxi tool that's a good news I think I
hope get ahead at XC 2 to irritate them
a little bit on IG three I can take C 2
so that I can we capture on f5 with the
Queen and there's also a funny tactical
idea if I go 97 or 96 I'm threatening
night takes five with the spinning motif
on the fourth-ranked so this this might
be very important this temple I actually
intend to play 97 so that I can okay now
i can take here yeah i mean this was the
idea all along so i'm going to do it
it's not totally clear that this is so
so bad for him but then I had no big big
choice him so what am I doing here is
what what he definitely has he is got
temple advantage and in time here he's
with quicker with age 6 may be coming
but I can take a knight c6 should be
really okay an endgame just with minor
pieces would be excellent of course
night against bishop is almost to win
here he's got I mean he's upon down and
he's got everything on dark square so
the night will be much better in a pure
minor piece and game looks like age 6
what else is there
want to open up the position
not every don't think it is sufficient I
think black is better here but I don't
see what else you should do instead of
age six
so night here for Luke g8 of the bishop
moves key idea is let's say Bishop e3
rook g8 i'm going to play night da to e6
if he allows that on e6 the nidus am an
excellent defender locator yeah so he's
not allowing it I can go to e6 though
yeah let's start with that if he goes
rook she wanna have route 87 and then I
need to try to regroup so that i can
actually free free myself on the Kings
side it's not easy it's not like an easy
we know anything he's got quite some
pressure here
97 and g6 this would be okay I can take
it with the real cried
or not takes with the rook what g6 and
after g6 very difficult to see how to
get get anywhere okay Bishop g5 is
prevented at the moment rook h8s is
irritating yeah check before I'm doing
something active on the Queen's oh this
is great yeah now I get rook strain it
this should actually be enough to win
this getting the rooks off off to see
form okay can go here too okay so he
didn't take no I can let let's check
here is this oh this is good yeah this
is good I cannot take at the moment he
has got the sea takes b6 tactic but I
can approach with the king check was may
be possible but this this should be or
b-five actually be Phi F is even
stronger right and yep
white resign yeah this is this is a win
with a pawn a pawn with a win so let's
do a quick recap yeah this is an
interesting line the g4 is a really
brutal way to play I took it I mean
first there and then this kind of thing
yeah Queen a4 was an interesting move I
think it gets this an end as mentioned
the idea here with night d7 with the
tempo so I don't know I mean it's not so
easy for him to actually defend the sea
to pawn if he does that which is what he
did I took pics yeah maybe this is
relatively speaking of the best he had
some compensation for this pawn I
actually was thinking that this might be
an idea this kind of thing jam how to
say if this is this is enough like this
okay here okay jus wanna is pretty quick
so this one yeah yeah I'm starting to
believe that black is getting somewhere
and after this some black is an
excellent shape yeah key moment is here
yeah yeah absolutely has to avoid the
Rope trade after the rook traded is lost
but yeah how actually how is he avoiding
it I cannot really yeah that that means
that through the end kami is winning
this is a winning end game with the
night
against the bishop I'm always getting
yeah I'm getting the decisive a pawn to
run and still he's got all on dark
square so it's likely to drop some of
those poems I liked it too drove okay
thanks a lot bye